good morning John I'm in Melbourne
Australia that's the convention center
where VidCon is currently happening as
of the release of this video but not
quite yet as of the recording of it more
on the city of my Australian publisher a
shet has asked me to answer some
questions about my book and since it's
coming out in less than 30 days I'm
gonna do that I'm doing it with the help
of some Australian voices because I love
this accent what's your writing routine
like guitar trying to be so austere
what's your writing routine lot i open
my laptop unless it's already open and
then i take why did you name your
protagonist april is this some kind of
metaphor here oh wow there's a lot of
water on the land i was pretty on the
page kind of writer like there's not a
lot of subtext honestly i like to be
pretty explicit but that being said i
mean there is reasons they're not really
metaphorical but you don't know that how
does writing a book change the way you
experience other books i can tell you
what definitely does change it I
wouldn't say it's better or worse first
of all it's harder to not compare myself
to good writers and be like oh I'm bad
at that the second like yeah you see
more of the process you see more of how
it works I think that that's a deeper
understanding but it's less immersive
maybe different not better or worse and
to be clear I find that with most media
I find it with video blogs music like
the things that I've tried my handout
that I spent time doing it affects the
way that you imagine and perceived them
it affects the way that you enjoy them
feel like any 5.1 ton load would be
pretty gross are there any songs you
listen to that inspired the plot or
characters in your novel I don't listen
to music while I'm writing I mean I
can't listen to anything while I'm
writing like white noise maybe but yes
it will become clear upon reading it
there a number of songs that were
inspirational in the book what have you
found to be the hardest part of writing
a book
stopping writing is really hard once
you've done it for so long like it's so
hard to get it out of your mind that you
can't change anything anymore
I thought of something really great last
night that I that would make the book
better if it was in there but it's not
gonna be I did put one thing in the book
after it went to press though so it'll
be in the second edition and also maybe
in the digital editions if someone
offers to make an absolutely remarkable
thing into a movie would you say yes I
don't know I haven't said yes yet to
that so we'll just have to see I guess
that would be pretty cool but it's also
a lot of work I've seen it it's a lot of
work loved your book
is there a say cool in the works thank
you for reading my book book store IND
yes where did you spend most of your
time writing your book I mean in chairs
most I'm not very picky I'll do it
wherever Hey I'm just blogging yeah I'm
in my hood it's raining outside will you
give us the robot slash car chasing that
John will never write I mean I am
looking for ideas like inspiration can
come from anywhere so maybe at which
point you go alright that's it this idea
is going to become a book about when I'm
finished
why did you write a slash this book I
make a lot of stuff and there are lots
of things that I've wanted to talk about
that I haven't found good ways to do
that and I found that this was a good
way to talk about stuff that I wanted to
talk about it's also a good way to tell
a really good story that I was really
excited about what was the seed for the
story that became the book kind of
embarrassing but a literal dream like I
had a dream 9 now that's interesting
well then I made a book when does the
book come out it comes out September
25th it's available for pre-order now
this is a beautiful city
if damp John I'll see you on Tuesday
you'll be able to get my book at places
like dyemax book lovers this must be a
very dangerous ladder there's got it
confined you're not going anywhere